[موسيقى]
إنه عام 2023. لقد تعهدت بأن تكون أكثر صحة
الآن ما يمكن أن تساعدك حيواناتك الأليفة حقًا على
القيام به ، أعني أن الحيوانات الأليفة قد ثبت
أنها تجلب لك إحساسًا أكبر بالصحة
والرفاهية بالنسبة لك. حجم هولي أكبر مع
أفضل أصدقاء الحيوان  يقول المجتمع إن الحيوانات الأليفة
يمكن أن تساعدك في الحفاظ على تلك
القرارات الصحية إذا كنت ترغب في تناول الطعام الصحي ،
تحقق مع طبيبك البيطري بشأن
الأطعمة التي يمكنك مشاركتها مع قطتك أو
كلبك والجزر والتفاح من الأطعمة الرائعة
وربما قطعة صغيرة من الجبن قد
لا تكون كذلك  صحي ولكن ربما
يحظى بتقدير كبير من قبل الكلب إذا كان هدفك هو التحرك أكثر في عام
2023 ، وحتى بعض
القطط يمكن أن تكون رفقاء رائعين في
نزهة ويمكن حتى تحميلك المسؤولية ،
وبمجرد أن يعتادوا على المشي ، فإنهم
سيحملونك على ذلك مثل  إذا كنت تمشي في
نفس الوقت كل يوم ، فعادةً ما
يبدأون في إرشادك قبل بضع دقائق
ويقولون إنني مستعد للمشي إذا كنت ترغب في
أن تكون أكثر اجتماعية في العام الجديد
مع وجود حيوان أليف  هي
طريقة رائعة لمقابلة الآخرين الذين أعتقد أنني
قابلت أبو  نصف جيراني بينما كنت
أسير مع كلبي وكان الأمر رائعًا للغاية
لأنني أعتقد أنني صنعت أصدقاء
ربما لم أكن لأحصل عليها بخلاف ذلك
لأنها مثل هذه الحيوانات الأليفة الرائعة لكسر الجليد يمكن أن
تساعد أيضًا في تقليل التوتر في حياتك ،
والفرح والحب غير المشروط
يزيلون التوتر في حد ذاته ولكن إذا كنت
ترغب في المضي قدمًا قليلاً ،
فيمكنك القيام بأشياء مثل التأمل مع حيوانك
الأليف أو ربما حتى اليوغا من أجل الصحة
، أنا آندي جاثر